WE WANT TO TAKE YOU LIVE TO
MOSCOW.
A PACKED HOUSE IN THE KREMLIN A
ST. GEORGE HALL.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL CEREMONY.
IT BEGINS THE PROCESS OF
FORMERLY ANNEXING ABOUT 18% OF
UKRAINE.
THIS MOVES COMES AFTER THE
SO-CALLED REFERENDUM IN THE
FOUR OCCUPIED TERRITORIES IN
THE EAST.
ACCORDING TO PRO RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS, VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORTED
JOINING RUSSIA.
THE VOTE IS WIDELY CONSIDERED A
SHAM.
IT IS CONSIDERED ILLEGAL UNDER
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
>> THERE IS THE RESULTS.
THEY HAVE BEEN UNKNOWN.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE MADE THEIR
CHOICE CLEAR.
IT IS A CLEAR CHOICE.
TODAY, WE ARE SIGNING AN
AGREEMENT ABOUT JOINING DONETSK
AND LUHANSK LUHANSK PEOPLE'S
REPUBLIC.
WE ARE SURE THAT OUR
LEGISLATIVE MODEL WILL APPROVE
ACCEPTING THESE FOUR NEW
SUBJECTS OF THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION.
IT IS THE WILL OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE.
IT IS THEIR RIGHT.
THIS IS THEIR RIGHT.
IT IS IN THE FIRST ARTICLE OF
THE UN STATUTE.
IT SAYS THAT THE DEFINITION OF
PEOPLE, IT IS FOUNDED ON THE
HISTORICAL UNITY OF GENERATIONS
OF OUR PEOPLE.
THEY WERE BUILDING AND
DEFENDING RUSSIA.
--
THEY WERE FIGHTING.
OUR GRANDFATHERS, OUR GREAT
GRANDFATHER'S, THEY WERE
FIGHTING JURY THE --
WE WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER THOSE
WHO DID NOT PUT UP IN 2014.
THEY DIED FOR THEIR RIGHT TO
SPEAK THEIR LANGUAGE, THE RIGHT
TO PRESERVE THEIR CULTURE, TO
LIVE.
WE --
, THE CIVILIANS, THE UKRAINIANS,
THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE, THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT NATIONALITIES.
--
THIS IS THE NEW LEADER NOW.
THEY PROSECUTED LUHANSK WE.
--
OUR MILITARY DIED DURING THIS
SPECIAL MILITARY OPERATION,
THEY ARE HEROES.
HEROES OF GREAT RUSSIA.
I ASK YOU TO HONOR THEIR MEMORY
WITH HIM IN A MINUTE OF
SILENCE.
THANK YOU.
THEY HAD A CHOICE OF MILLIONS
OF RESIDENTS.
I.
--
WE HAVE HISTORY.
THE SPIRITUAL TIES WERE PASSED
DOWN GENERATIONS.
THEY BROUGHT THIS FEELING TO
RUSSIA.
NOBODY CAN DESTROY IT IS
FEELING.
THIS IS WHY ALL OF THE PEOPLE,
THE YOUNG PEOPLE, THOSE WHO
WERE BORN AFTER THE COLLAPSE OF
THE SOVIET UNION, THEY VOTED
FOR OUR FUTURE IN 1991.
THE REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
PARTY MADE A DECISION.
PEOPLE ENDED UP TORN.
THERE IS A NATIONAL
CATASTROPHE.
IT WAS SOME TIME AFTER THE
REVOLUTION.
--
IN THIS TIME AFTER THE
REFERENDUM OF 1991, OUR GREAT
MODEL WAS DESTROYED.
PEOPLE WILL BE PUT BEFORE THE
FACT.
THEY DID NOT EVEN REALIZE WHAT
THEY WERE DOING.
THEY DID NOT REALIZE THE
CONSEQUENCES IT WOULD HAVE.
IT DOES NOT MATTER ANYMORE.
THERE IS NO SOVIET UNION
ANYMORE.
YOU CANNOT RETURN IN THE PAST.
TODAY'S RUSSIA DOES NOT NEED IT
ANYMORE.
THEY DON'T STRIVE FOR THIS.
THERE IS NOTHING STRONGER THAN
THE DESIRE OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE.
BY THEIR CULTURE AND LANGUAGE,
THEY CONSIDER THEMSELVES PART
OF RUSSIA.
THEIR GRANDPARENTS LIVED IN
RUSSIA.
THEY HAVE THE DESIRE TO RETURN
TO THEIR HISTORIC --
IT IS DURING THE LONG YEARS.
PEOPLE --
THERE WAS GENOCIDE AGAINST THEM.
THERE IS THE HATRED TO RUSSIA.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WERE
THREATENED FOR THEIR DESIRE IN
THE REFERENDUM.
I WANT THE --
I WANT THEM TO HEAR ME AND
REMEMBER.
BECOMING OUR CITIZENS FOREVER.
[APPLAUSE] WE WANT THEM TO
IMMEDIATELY A CEASE-FIRE AND
ALL MILITARY ACTIONS.
THE WAR STARTED BACK IN 2014.
IT RETURNED TO THE NEGOTIATION
TABLE.
WE ARE PREPARED FOR THIS.
THE CHOICE OF THE PEOPLE, WE
ARE NOT GOING TO DISCUSS.
RUSSIA IS NOT GOING TO PORTRAY
THEM.
KYIV IS ALREADY FREE.
THERE IS THIS EXPRESSION OF
WILL.
--
THIS IS THE ONLY WAY TO PEACE.
WE WILL DEFEND IT BY ALL MEANS.
WE WILL DO EVERYTHING TO DEFEND
THE LIFE OF THE PEOPLE.
WE WILL BE BELOW THE DESTROYED
CITIES AND VILLAGES, THE
SCHOOLS AND HOSPITALS.
WE WILL DEVELOP INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE WANT EDUCATION, HEALTH CARE.
WE WILL MAKE SURE HERE THAT ALL
REPUBLICS AND AREAS OF OUR HUGE
MODEL HAVE PROSPERITY.
>> I WANT TO ADDRESS OUR
SOLDIERS AND OFFICERS YOU
PARTICIPATE IN THE SPECIAL
MILITARY OPERATION.
IN THE DONBAS.
THERE ARE THOSE WHO --
THERE IS THE PARTIAL
MOBILIZATION.
I WANT TO ADDRESS THEIR PARENTS,
WIVES, AND CHILDREN.
I WILL TELL THEM WHAT OUR
PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING AGAINST.
WHO IS OUR ENEMY?
WHO IS THROWING US INTO THE
CRISIS?
THEY WANT TO BENEFIT FROM
EIGHT.
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN THE
UKRAINE HAVE SEEN IT WITH THEIR
OWN EYES.
THERE IS THE LEADING OF THE
WEST.
THEY HAVE THROWN OFF THEIR
MASKS.
THEY HAVE SHOWN THEIR NATURE.
AFTER THE COLLAPSE OF THE
SOVIET UNION, THEY DECIDED THAT
WE WILL ALL HAVE TO PUT UP WITH
A DICTATORSHIP.
THERE IS THE TIME THE WEST SAW
THAT RUSSIA WAS NOT GOING TO
SURVIVE THIS.
THIS NEARLY HAPPENED.
WE REMEMBER THE SITUATION FROM
THE 19 90S.
RUSSIA HAS SURVIVED.
THEY BECAME STRONGER.
THEY HAVE THEIR PLACES IN THE
WORLD.
THE WEST IS STILL TRYING TO
MAKE AS WEAKER.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SPLIT US
INTO PARTS.
THEY CAN'T PUT UP WITH THE FACT
THAT THERE IS SUCH A HUGE
COUNTRY.
THERE IS THE NATURAL RESOURCES.
THEY ARE NOT PREPARED TO LIVE
UNDER THE WESTERN COMMAND.
THE WEST CAN NOT BELIEVE THEIR
COLONIAL MENTALITY.
THEY WANT TO TRY AND RECEIVE
HEGEMONY.
THERE IS THE RESERVATION.
IT IS THEIR KEY MOTIVE.
THIS IS THE REASON OF THE
AGGRESSION INTO THE INDEPENDENT
COUNTRIES, WITH TRADITIONAL
VALUES AND CULTURES.
HENCE THEIR ATTEMPT TO
UNDERMINE THE CENTER OF
DEVELOPMENT.
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THEM THAT
ALL OF THE COUNTRIES SURRENDER
THEIR SOVEREIGNTY --
THEY NEED TO VOLUNTARILY BECOME
--
IF COUNTRIES DO NOT AGREE TO
THIS, THEY TRY TO RUIN THIS
COUNTRY.
MILLIONS OF KILLED PEOPLE.
THEIR LIVES WERE PROTECTING
COLONIES.
THEY DON'T CARE.
AS LONG AS THEY RECEIVE THEIR
PROFITS.
THEY AGREED.
IT WAS THEIR ATTEMPT TO
PRESERVE THEIR POWER.
THAT IS THE REASON FOR THIS
KIND OF RETURN TO THE WEST.
IT IS THE COLLECTIVE WEST.
IT IS LEADING AGAINST RUSSIA.
THEY WANT TO SEE US AS A
COLONY.
THEY WANT THIS INSTEAD OF
CORPORATION.
THEY WANT TO RULE US.
THEY WANT TO RULE OUR THOUGHTS
AND PHILOSOPHIES.
IT IS A DIRECT THREAT TO THEM.
OUR CULTURE IS A THREAT TO THEM.
THIS IS WHY THEY WANT TO FORBID
IT.
OUR DEVELOPMENT AND PROSPERITY
IS A THREAT TO THEM.
THEY DON'T NEED RUSSIA.
WE DO NEED IT.
[APPLAUSE] I WANT TO REMIND YOU
THAT THEIR ATTEMPT TO BECOME
MASTERS OF THE WORLD WAS NOT A
SUCCESSFUL.
WE ARE GOING TO DEFEND OUR
COUNTRY.
THE WEST IS HOPING THAT THEY
WILL REMAIN ON PUNISHED FOR
EVERYTHING.
THEY'RE AGREEMENTS FOR A
STRATEGIC STRATEGIES GO TO THE
BAN.
THEIR TREATMENTS AND PROMISES
ARE NOT SO --
THAT IS TO THE EAST.
THERE IS THE AGREEMENT ABOUT
MISSILES.
THEY HAVE BEEN BROKEN.
WE CAN HEAR FROM ALL SIDES THAT
THE WEST IS SPENDING THE WORLD
ORDER.
THAT IS BASED ON THE RULES.
IT IS SOME DELIRIUM.
COMPLETE LIES.
DOUBLE OR TRIPLE STANDARDS.
IT IS FOR FOOLS ONLY.
RUSSIA IS A COUNTRY OF GREAT
CIVILIZATION.
IT WILL NOT LIVE UNDER THESE
RULES.
THEY BROKE THE PRINCIPLE OF
THEIR BORDER.
THE BORDERS WE ARE NOT
BREAKING.
NOW THEY ARE DECIDING WHO IS --
WHO GAVE THEM THIS RIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW.
THIS IS WHY THEY ARE SO ANGRY
ABOUT IT IN CRIMEA.
THEY ARE ANGRY ABOUT THE OTHER
FOUR REGIONS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
SPEAK ABOUT DEMOCRACY.
THE WESTERN HEGEMONY HAS --
THEY ARE SO-CALLED DEVELOPED
AND NON-DEVELOPED.
BARBARIANS.
THE AUTHORITARIAN REGIME.
OTHERS ARE GIVEN TO LOT OF
COUNTRIES.
THERE IS NOTHING NEW ABOUT IT.
THE WESTERN ALLIES ARE
COLONIALIST'S.
IT IS THE SAME AS BEFORE.
THEY DISCRIMINATE.
THEY DIVIDE OTHER COUNTRIES.
CÔTE D'IVOIRE --
IT IS SPREADING NOW ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
THERE IS RACISM.
THAT NEOLIBERAL CULTURAL, THEY
THINK IT IS AN EXAMPLE FOR THE
WHOLE WORLD.
WHOEVER IS NOT WITH US IS
AGAINST US.
THIS SOUNDS STRANGE.
THE WESTERN ELITES ARE FORCING
OTHER COUNTRIES TO APOLOGIZE
FOR THINGS THAT HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH THEM.
FOR EXAMPLE, COLONIALISM.
LET ME REMIND YOU THAT THE WEST
WAS DEALING WITH SLAVERY,
COLONIALISM.
THAT WAS BACK IN THE MIDDLE
AGES.
>> THIS IS WHAT SOME MIGHT
DESCRIBE AS A POLITICAL AND
HISTORICAL SPEECH.
THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT ADDRESSED
AN AUDIENCE OF DIGNITARIES,
RELIGIOUS LEADERS, THEY WERE
GATHERED IN ST. GEORGE HALL IN
THE KREMLIN.
THAT IS AHEAD OF SIGNING
DECREES THAT FORMALLY ANNEX
NEARLY 20% OF UKRAINE INTO
RUSSIA.
THERE ARE NOW FOUR NEW REGIONS
OF RUSSIA, HE SAID, HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE VOTE.
THEY WERE REFERENDUMS.
PUTIN SAID THAT THE PEOPLE HAD
MADE THEIR CHOICE, HE SAID IT
IS THE WOOLLY WILL OF MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE.
HE SAID IT TO APPLAUSE FROM
THOSE GATHERED IN THE HALL.
HE WENT ON TO DESCRIBE THAT
VOTE AT THIS DECISION.
HE SAID IT IS THEIR RIGHT.
IT IS IN SHINED IN THE UN
CHARTER.
LET'S DISCUSS WHETHER THERE IS
ANY VERACITY TO THAT.
FROM WHAT WE UNDERSTAND, CNN
NATIONAL SECURITY EDITOR NICK
PATON WALSH IS JOINING ME FROM
THE UKRAINE.
CNN CORRESPONDENT IS IN LONDON.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF WHAT YOU
HEARD SO FAR?
>> TWO THINGS THAT REALLY STAND
OUT FOR ME.
THE TOP NEWS LINE FROM THIS IS
AS EXPECTED.
HE IS CALLING FOR A UNILATERAL
CEASE FIRE.
HE'S ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT
THESE FOUR NEW AREAS THAT ARE
NOT PART OF UKRAINE, RUSSIA NOW
SAYS THEY ARE PART OF RUSSIA,
THEY ARE OCCUPIED PARTIALLY,
BUT THEY ARE NOT UP FOR
DISCUSSION.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE PLAY
BEHIND ALL OF THIS WAS.
THE KREMLIN, AS THEY DID AGAIN
HERE, THEY WILL USE ALL MEANS
AVAILABLE TO THEM TO DEFEND
THESE AREAS.
THEY ARE DECLARING THE PART OF
RUSSIA.
RIGHT, LET'S HAVE A PEACEFUL
SETTLEMENT.
THEY ARE PUTTING PRESSURE ON
THE QUESTION BACKERS OF
UKRAINE.
THEY ARE PUSHING UKRAINE
TOWARDS THE NEGOTIATING TABLE.
PERHAPS THE OTHER PLAYERS
AROUND HERE.
TURKEY, FOR EXAMPLE, THEIR
PRESENCE IS ON THE PHONE TO HIM.
THEY SPOKE ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
IT IS CLEAR THAT MILITARILY
THEY ARE STILL LOSING HERE.
THEY'RE LOSING STARKLY.
THE SECOND THING THAT STRUCK ME
IS THIS EXTRAORDINARY SPLIT
SCREEN FICTIONAL HISTORY
LESSON.
ALL OF THIS IS BECAUSE NATO IS
EXPANDING EASTWARDS.
ALL OF THIS IS BECAUSE OF THE
POOR CONDUCT OF THE LAST.
THEY ARE TREATING RUSSIA AND
OTHER COUNTRIES LIKE COLONIAL
SUBJECTS.
RUSSIA HAS ITSELF BEEN ACCUSED
OF THAT.
THEY ARE MAKING A CASE FOR THE
CONTINUATION OF THIS WAR.
I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE
PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE, BUT THE
FACES --
THIS IS CLEARLY THE ELITE.
THEY ARE STILL REELING FROM
WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN SEEING OVER
THE PAST MONTH OR SO.
VERY IMPASSIONED, VERY FAMILIAR
CASE.
THIS IS ALL NOT RUSSIA'S FAULT.
IT HAS BEEN BACK IN THIS
CORNER.
THEY ARE DEFENDING THEMSELVES.
THESE ARGUMENTS DO HOLD NO
CURRENCY GLOBALLY.
>> WHETHER THEY HAVE MADE ANY
MARK IN THE ROOM, WE WILL FIND
THAT OUT IN THE WEEKS AHEAD.
A VERY CLEAR MESSAGE, FRANKLY,
IF YOU WANT TO TAKE AWAY ONE
THING FROM THIS, IT IS VLADIMIR
PUTIN SAYING THAT THEY SHOULD
NOW HAVE A CEASE-FIRE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT PEACE.
WE KNOW THAT RUSSIA USES
DIPLOMACY AS A PAUSE TO
MILITARY ENDS.
THEY ARE FAILING HERE.
WASHINGTON AND KYIV HAVE SAID
THERE IS VERY LITTLE REASON TO
SEE IT GO SHE ASIANS MOVING
FORWARD HERE.
AT THIS POINT, HE IS HOLDING
OUT THE POINT --
THEY ARE LOSING STRATEGIC
POSITION IN THE LUHANSK AREA.
THEY CLAIMED IT IS PART OF
RUSSIA.
WE HAVE YET TO FIND AN ANSWER
IN THE REALITY.
HERE'S THE SPLIT SCREEN
PARALLEL OF WHAT THE KREMLIN
SAID THIS IS GOING ON ON THE
GROUND.
WE ARE DEFINITELY SEEING THEM
LOSING.
THESE ARE THE AREAS THAT ARE
DECLARED A PART OF RUSSIA.
UKRAINE IS CONTROLLING MORE AND
MORE BY THE HOUR.